with Saturday Night Live when you go
there you didn't think of yourself as a
sketch writer now I didn't come to get
to John Howard I literally went to tell
them how dope I was in was gonna tell
them no right I really came out so
people can see me and maybe there was
gonna give me some opportunities but I
had all plans to saying no who got you
the audition Chris Rock Chris did he did
he's a good [ __ ] guy yeah he saw me
at the Comedy Store one late night doing
a spot and he was like yep she's next
level she's ready Chris so Chris Rock
heard your act and instead of like being
a guy who goes this is a secure guy
because as a lot of comics are insecure
they're going on Connery's do funny I'm
not gonna recommend her to Saturday
Night Live right he literally wrote down
your name right hey yeah it's funny
people book and I guess he went to Lorne
Michaels at some point said here's
somebody funny literally he called I
think he called me and it was like hey I
just talked to Lauren I just had dinner
with Lauren somebody from SNL is gonna
contact you for an audition and I was
like why the [ __ ] would you do that I am
NOT a sketch what the [ __ ] Chris I don't
do that [ __ ] right you're smoking stand
up I'm not gonna be able to do that [ __ ]
he said shut the [ __ ] up go out there
and do stand-up I wanna hear the [ __ ]
and hung up now when you had your
audition the way I understand it and I
love this about you I just watch so
anxious to talk that's why I'm so glad
that they got me at the age I got Matt -
yeah because you wouldn't have done this
I would not have done this before Lauren
and his henchmen we're all sitting in
the back in the back in the dark you
know and straddle and you get up on that
stage and you say what well the first
thing is the girls were coming out
shell-shocked and I'm like what's going
on in here so as soon as I got into the
corridor where we were going oh I
thought to myself oh this is the Comedy
Store two o'clock at night hell yeah I'm
about to rip this [ __ ] so I got
on stage and there was empty chairs in
the fibers like that's not how I work
let's go everybody move to the front
[Music]
which why not was that done out of an
insecurity and waiting nervous actually
give two [ __ ] in the [ __ ]
they did what they had to do and I
started my act you got the whole
audience to move